hey guys I'm Abby Shar welcome to Abby's
kitchen so a while ago I gave you a
little bit of an update to my
breastfeeding struggles so if you missed
this video you can check it out right
here but here's a little recap for you
so back in that video what I was
discussing was that I was having some
serious supply issues so I had to go on
domperidone to up my breast milk supply
so I could make enough to feed my son
we're also having a lot of latching
issues because my son had a lip and a
tongue tie so he got that removed but we
still were definitely struggling with
the breast feeding so as a result we
were trying to breastfeed pretty much
every day but ultimately I was mostly
doing pumping so that's where I was at
that video but I wanted to of course
update you on all the changes that have
happened
[Music]
I basically just gave up on
breastfeeding altogether and since then
my son is being exclusively fed pumped
milk it became really exhausting to like
basically how to feed three different
ways every single feed multiple times a
day because I was trying to breastfeed
and then he was screaming and then I
give him the bottle and I've seen the
bottle and then I'd have to pump and
then I'd have to do that all day and
night and it was really really
interfering with my my well-being and my
my ability to kind of get through every
single day the thought of having to do
that for an entire year was like
inconceivable though most moms will
probably agree that exclusively pumping
is already so much work it's absolutely
exhausting so throwing breastfeeding in
the mix there was making me a miserable
human being
I was also pumping like every single
hour on the hour so that was definitely
getting exhausted but since then my
supply has steadied and I've actually
been able to freeze quite a lot of
breast milk so to date I have frozen
over 40 litres of breast milk I'm very
proud of my stash the things that I was
doing was taking mother's milk
supplements every day blessed thistle
supplements I was also eating a lot of
the boob foods that we've also talked
about in the past whether or not they
worked I don't know I was pumping
constantly I was pumping every hour on
the hour at the beginning and then I was
able to drop to every two hours for a
total of nine pumps every single day and
I was taking domperidone which is a
common drug often used to increase
breast milk supply and I was taking 12
pills every single day so that was like
a pretty high dose and one thing we'll
be able to kind of establish a good
amount of supply on that and doing all
of those things I was able to make my
life a little bit more manageable and
for me that really started with getting
off the domperidone so once I was
holding steady at producing enough
breast milk I started to drop my dumb
parrot on pills so the regime was
basically dropping a 1 pill of
domperidone every
week very very slowly so that my supply
would not plumb it and then amazingly
after a few months I was able to
completely get off the drugs and that
was a really really exciting day and
then my next goal was of course to start
to drop the pump so from 9 pumps a day
which was really really exhausting and
excessive I was able to get down to
eight pumps a day and then from eight
pumps a day I was able to get to seven
pumps day a few weeks later
so after holding steady at like 7 pumps
this whole period where I was getting
off the domperidone
and just dropping pump I started to get
a lot of blocked ducts and these block
ducts are painful in their own right but
four times
I got mastitis from them and if you
don't know about sizes count your lucky
stars but basically it's the
inflammation and an infection of the
milk ducts and it can cause fever
it can cause it's doston a lot of breast
pain and of course a drop and supply
because you're having these milk ducts
get really clogged up and I had it four
times it was brutal
and I did everything that you know you
read a bit online and all the moms tell
you to do so cabbage in your bra and
like crazy massages and I was having hot
showers every hour and like dipping my
boobs into like a hot bath on all fours
it was like it was not bad so this past
weekend I just like kind of felt like
enough was enough I was dealing with the
worst case of block ducts I've had so
since like I gave birth it literally
felt like I had a million little knot in
both breasts I wasn't getting any milk
out I was totally miserable it was so
painful and I kind of felt like I should
I give up like is this the men's of my
breast feeding and pumping journey like
do I just throw in the towel right now I
was like sitting in the bath on Friday
night just crying like I couldn't even
like get myself out of the bath to like
just feed my son and move on and I
wanted to have a nice night with my
husband but I just felt so down on
myself like I really really let myself
down on that
so the next morning I had a lactation
consultant come over to my house to try
to relieve me of these blockages and
even she couldn't get them out but what
she did do was recommend that I go up
inside in the flange the the piece that
goes on my breast pump and that actually
made a world of a difference instantly
as soon as I tried it Thank You Amazon
Prime for sending it so quickly but as
soon as I tried it I started to feel the
blockages coming out and I was starting
to get more milk out in each and every
pump so pumping Mama's if you are
constantly getting block duct or
mastitis maybe consider getting your
flange size re-evaluated I had no idea
that this was gonna make that kind of
difference also what I did yesterday was
I went to see an acupuncturist who
specializes in kind of milk ducts and
mastitis and not only does he do some
acupuncture but she also did some like
manual manipulation which was brutally
painful imagine having your nipple like
a purple nipple twisted for an hour
that's what it felt like but it actually
really really worked and I think I am on
the mend so guys I'm really really
hoping that making some of these changes
are going to help me in keeping this
even is going so that I can hopefully
drop another pump or two in the next few
months and maybe just maybe I will be
able to sleep through the night before
my son turns one that is my life goal
right now so mamas I hope you enjoyed
this video if you did be sure to give me
the thumbs up please give me some
support thank you guys for your support
on social media when I complain about
all these issues I would love to hear
from you and your breast feeding
journeys what is your journey look like
what have you found to increase your
supply have you had chronic block ducts
to mastitis I would love to hear what
will has worked well for you don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and I
will see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]